hello everybody good morning to you it's
seven o'clock the government is
resisting calls for a u-turn on the mini
budget despite a run on the pound and
the markets being plunged into turmoil
but Downing Street has moved to restore
order to the public finances with
ministers told to find Savings in their
departments we'll speak to the chief
secretary to the treasury about which
services will now be cut to fund tax
cuts for the highest earners and will
the lights go out in Europe this winter
we're going to be asking Denmark's
foreign minister about the implications
of an apparent attack on a major gas
pipeline it's Thursday the 29th of
September
well the treasury says it has the right
plan to grow the economy despite the
market backlash
the bank of England is forced to spend
65 billion pounds on emergency action to
save Britain's Pension funds
also ahead 20 people missing off the
Florida coast and almost 2 million
without power after one of the most
powerful storms ever recorded I'm in
Fort Myers close to where hurricane Ian
K Michelle and where Coastal communities
have been utterly devastated
a defense Source tells Sky News that
pipelines carrying Russian gas to Europe
were probably attacked with underwater
explosives detonated remotely
[Music]
the rapper and actor Coolio dies at the
age of 59.
also ahead this morning we'll hear from
the health Security Agency about their
fears that Britain could be heading for
a flu coveted twin demic this winter and
why people need to get vaccinated
Nando
[Music]
I'll speak to the rapper lethal Bizzle
as he wins an award for pushing Grime
into the mainstream
[Music]
hello very good morning to you the
government is insisting there'll be no
u-turn on the Chancellor's mini budget
despite turmoil in the markets the bank
of England has been forced into
emergency action over what it called a
material risk to the UK's Financial
stability the central bank has launched
a 65 billion pound Bond buying program
after a mass sell-off led to a run on
British Pension funds
well let's get the latest from our
business correspondent Paul Kelsey who
joins me now so Paul just how unusual
was this intervention into the bond
market by the bank of England which was
kicked off yesterday
extremely unusual for the bank to wade
into the market in the way it has an
even more unusual for a central bank to
have to take action to prop up
fundamental parts of the economic
architecture and structure of the
economy because of the actions of a
government the move in the pensions
Market was a very real threat to the
stability of that market around a
trillion pounds worth of assets held in
various ways that became threatened by
the collapse in bond prices bonds are
supposed to be UK bonds government bonds
are supposed to be the risk-free way of
borrowing because you're borrowing
against the competence and stability of
a government and UK government bonds I
mean they were gold-plated almost
literally they had guilt edges uh Once
Upon a Time which is why they're called
guilt but the government's moving the
budget on Friday the Market's loss of
Faith subsequently meant the value of
bonds halved it left lots of Pension
funds exposed they borrow Road against
them hence they needed to sell quickly
the price of the bonds fell even more
and the bank had to step in now for now
they do seem to have righted the ship
the run on pensions Investments that has
been averted but this is a consequence
of a lack of faith and a knock to
confidence in the UK government's
economic plan its competence and frankly
the stability of the UK economy so
recovering that confidence in markets is
going to take time we'll start to hear
ministers we began last night we'll hear
more from them today the Prime Minister
will speak today attempting to explain
the economic plan that by that they set
out on Friday which caused this and so
they will be watching very closely Mark
is to hear whether the UK's plan makes
sense very interesting to me that Mark
Carney the former Governor of the bank
of England overnight has been critical
of the way that plan was set out and the
one thing we still don't know and in a
sense can't know is what other slightly
dark or usually ignored corners of the
UK's Financial Plumbing have been gummed
up or sprung a leak as a consequence of
this huge shock to the system that
happened on Friday so much still to play
for for the government to restore Market
confidence in their plan
Paul Kelso thanks very much indeed so
let's hear from the government now I'm
joined by the chief secretary to the
treasury Chris filth good morning to you
thanks very much India for joining us
good morning emergency budgets are
usually designed to solve an emergency
this one seems to have created one well
this was a growth plan designed to get
the UK economy growing ultimately the
only way that families and households
across the UK are going to see their
incomes sustainably Rising the only way
we're going to see good new jobs getting
created and ultimately the sustainable
tax base delivered to fund our Public
Services like police health education
and so on is by getting our economy
growing that's what the plan aims to do
partly through tax cuts but also through
supply side reforms reducing business
regulation building more infrastructure
like Road and rail more quickly building
energy infrastructure so we're not
dependent on energy Imports those parts
of the plan I think all of those
together will get our economy growing
okay and ultimately put us in a much
better position okay so you say it's
going to be good for people and yet the
reaction on the market has been
horrendous and people this morning will
be waking up they were already worried
about Rising Bells now they're also
worried about their mortgages and their
pensions as well so what would you say
to them well look I think on the
question about interest rates and more
and mortgage costs therefore by
extension I mean across the world for
the last probably six or nine months
we've seen an arising interest rate
cycle about central banks around the
world of club race in fact the U.S
federal reserve have put up interest
rates by more than the UK's Bank of
England and that's in response to the
inflation the global inflation caused by
Putin's illegal invasion of Ukraine and
in fact one of the reasons why this
growth package is so important and why
it included tax cuts is to alleviate the
burden placed on households and why it
also confirmed the energy intervention
making sure that households don't pay on
average more than two and a half
thousand pounds this winter and indeed
for the next two years for field you
remember just a few weeks ago people
were talking about energy bills this
winter of five six even seven thousand
Pounds a year and thanks to that
intervention last week by the Prime
Minister and by the chancellor that is
not going to happen so we've taken that
action to protect households at this
time of unprecedented lots of other
problems as I've said we've seen
um you know changes in or turbulence in
Global Financial markets for a number of
months not just here but around the
world the Bank of America correspondent
just a minute ago
um talked about the bank of England's
intervention yesterday of course the
bank of Japan intervened actually in
their currency Market uh just a few days
ago so other central banks are having to
take action as well the bank of England
did what it was supposed to acting of
course independently and it had its
desired effects and by the end of
yesterday
um the market had settled down again you
say it's a global problem the IMF hasn't
had to issue a stinging rebuke to any
other G7 country has it you know I saw
the imf's comments and I respectfully uh
disagree with them the response that I'm
sort of most interested in is the
response by British business
organizations who represent the
businesses the British businesses that
are going to grow that are going to
create these jobs and if you look at
what organizations like the CBI the
Confederate duration of British industry
the Federation of small businesses the
British Chambers of Commerce said last
Friday in response to the growth plan
all of them welcomed it really strongly
because speaking for their members they
can see it's going to grow our economy
okay so so business groups liked it and
would you agree that although some of
the tax cuts were well received you just
went too far
well look I think on the tax question
um I think we had very high levels of
Taxation and they were due to go up even
further that was the previous plan uh in
fact the corporation tax cut wasn't the
cut it was just keeping tax levels where
they are and reversing a very recent
National Insurance increase the view we
take is that in order for an economy to
grow we have to be have competitive
rates of tax to incentivize investment
but also to encourage both very
successful people and also businesses to
choose to locate in the UK so I used to
be technology Minister until just
recently and you know the most
successful technology businesses in the
world and the most successful technology
professionals you know coders and so on
they can choose where to locate they
haven't got to come to the UK and by
having a competitive rate of tax
compared to other countries we can
attract people to the United Kingdom to
make a contribution to pay their taxes
critically and to help grow the economy
and create new jobs but the markets were
prepared for some tax cuts but not to
this degree was it really necessary to
scrap the 45p rate which only benefits
at the really wealthy anyway it's not
even due to come in until April it
didn't need to be announced now and take
people by surprise well I think a couple
of points firstly the the top rated 40
40 so now 40 reducing from 45
um makes us internationally competitive
it puts us on a par with a number of
other uh the only benefits are wealthy
um well it it's true it benefits people
who earn more than 150 000 pounds but
very often those are people who are
internationally mobile they can choose
where to locate people I mean I talk to
people who have got a choice about
whether they work and live in you know
London or Edinburgh or Birmingham or
whether they go and live in Singapore or
New York or somewhere and we want those
people to locate here in the UK and so
one other point in terms of the size of
that measure
um it amounted to about to less than one
twentieth less than five percent of the
total fiscal measures it was a very
small part of the package most of the
measures like cutting National Insurance
and cutting the basic rate of income tax
which were the biggest the most
expensive measures they made up sort of
80 of it and those are targeted at
everybody everyone benefits you me
everybody but but the truth is the
markets weren't properly prepared were
they for what came at them and when you
when the mini budget was announced it
didn't have the obr's independent
assessment of what it meant for the
economy and how it was going to be paid
for and that spooked the markets they
were badly prepared weren't they and
that's why well I can't comment on
Marketplace headedness but I can no I
mean sorry the markets weren't prepared
for what you announced you didn't
prepare the markets well I think I mean
quite a few of the measures particularly
the more expensive ones like the energy
intervention to protect households the
National Insurance reversal and
corporation tax have been sort of quite
well trailed in advance
um but we are going to do of course a
full obr scoring in fact we're going to
do it twice this year as we're required
to do by law once on the 23rd of
November that's eight weeks away well
once on the 23rd of November wanted to
be done properly
um and and again with the spring budgets
there'll be two obr scorings this year
which is required by law
um we're also going to be setting out
the chancellor rather we'll set out his
medium-term fiscal plan which will
ensure that debt government debt as a
proportion of GDP the size of our
economy Falls over time uh because we
are going to do this responsibly and we
should remember of course that we start
this in a good position as a country
because our existing debt to GDP ratio
that's the measure most people use is
the second lowest in the G7 Jared Lyons
who you will know I'm sure often
referred to as Liz truss's favorite
Economist said that quasiquartang had
failed to adequately prepare the
financial markets ahead of this
announcement I'm looking said that quasi
quite the chancellor is in uh constant
contact with the markets he's meeting
the governor of the bank of England on a
very regular basis he I think just
yesterday he had meetings together with
his colleagues with financial Market
participants I think he's had several
meetings with them in the last week or
so and so I don't think I accept that
but he is in constant contact with
Market participants doesn't the obr need
to produce its report sooner than the
end of November well I think we're going
to do this just in an orderly fashion we
set a very clear date the 23rd of
November they'll do a full scoring of uh
of the measures that have been taken
they'll update their forecasts um let's
just do it in a in a measured organized
way that is the right way to approach
this and that's what we'll get on the
the 23rd in addition to our medium-term
fiscal plan has the government made any
mistakes
uh well no one's perfect
um but I think I'm not going to sort of
apologize for having a plan to grow the
UK's economy which will increase
people's wages that will create new jobs
I'm certainly not going to apologize for
having an energy Intervention which is
protecting every single household in
this country from what could have been
devastating bills this winter you say no
one's perfect to acknowledge that some
mistakes were made well look I'm not
going to get into this sort of um well
why not post-facto uh raking over but
the point I want to make most clearly is
the one I just made which is having a
growth plan to grow jobs increase
people's wages make sure the UK is
internationally competitive introduce
supply side reforms things like the
transport infrastructure reducing
business business regulation all of that
will make the whole country ultimately
better off and I say the energy
intervention is protecting every single
household in this country from what
would otherwise have been devastating
bills you say it's going to make the
country better off or what about public
spending you've asked government
departments for efficiency savings
haven't you that's right so on the
public spending side side two points to
make on how this gets paid for I mean
clearly growth is part of it if we grow
the economy it generates more taxes how
long will that take and we set out
actually in the in the Blue Book last
week on page 27
um it illustrates that if we can get our
economy growing by one percent faster
than it otherwise would uh after five
years that generates 47 billion pounds
of additional um tax revenue but we're
also going to be responsible with public
spending as you just um sort of
suggested which means first of all uh
sticking within the existing spending
limits the so-called um spending Review
21 limits that was a review done about a
year ago it covered Three Financial
years we're in the first of those years
now we are going to stick to those
spending limits so the efficiency and
prioritization exercise that you
referred to
um is designed to uh do two things
firstly make absolutely sure we stick to
those spending limits and secondly make
sure that we're prioritizing expenditure
uh not on anything that's wasteful but
on things that really deliver Frontline
public services and drive economic
growth people have heard so many times
before efficiency savings being sought
from departments this basically means
that
all departments are going to face a
squeeze aren't they but we found about
three over three billion pounds of
efficiency savings last year as I say we
actually we're going to stick to the to
the the spending and so-called spending
envelope we're going to stick to those
planned spending levels that were set
out a year ago over the next three year
period but we're going to make sure that
we're spending the money in the best
possible way and we're going to make
sure we don't exceed those limits so
with inflation at 10 your money just
isn't going to go as far and and
departments like the NHS like the Health
Service just can't cope can they I mean
Charlie Bean former governor of the bank
of England said spending cuts made
necessary by this mini budget could
finish the NHS well the NHS has had a
record funding settlement and to be
clear the inflation
um that is felt by the public sector is
different to the inflation felt by sort
of you and I as just consumers I said
it's a lower figure and even despite the
higher inflation that we've seen
recently it's a global phenomenon caused
by Putin's illegal invasion of Ukraine
despite that the spending envelope the
spending levels that we're working
within will still see real terms
increases public spending adjusting for
public sector inflation but we are going
to stick absolutely
rigidly to those spending limits because
it is important to be financially
responsible a lot of people are fairly
horrified by what's been going on the
market it's not least Tory MPS who some
publicly a lot privately have talked
about their discomfort should
quasi-cotting resign no I don't think
you should the chancellor has I think
set out very clearly a vision for growth
to get our economy growing that is what
we need and if you think about just
think about this in the sort of medium
term what we need is an economy that is
delivering the jobs of the future
attracting people and companies from
around the world to uh who are
successful to to work and to and to
produce jobs here and that is the right
plan and he's and he's fixed and he and
the Prime Minister working together have
fixed this energy uh crisis for families
they would we would have had bills of
six thousand pounds that's you know they
intervened to stop that and that's the
right thing to do and I think families
up and down the country will be pleased
they've got a prime minister and a
chancellor who have taken
urgent decisive action to protect them
from the effects of Putin's War when it
comes to energy bills okay Chris philp
Chief secretary to the treasury thanks
very much indeed thank you
let's take a look at how the morning
papers are covering this story many of
them focusing course on this crisis in
the financial markets and the financial
times leads with the bank of England's
extraordinary intervention in an attempt
to head off the negative reaction of
worldwide markets to the government's
mini budget
Guardian their headline Banks 65 billion
pound gamble to avert financial crisis
the eye describes the move as an effort
to save pensions
the star pictures the chancellor of
quasi-quartering with the paper joking
that he's asking colleagues does anyone
have a clue what I'm doing
even the express which usually supports
the government dubs it a day of turmoil
and the bank's intervention is also the
main concern for the Daily Telegraph
this morning
and just to let you know that later on
today at 12 o'clock Jane second will be
presenting a special program on Sky News
about the current crisis in the markets
and she's going to be joined by our
economics editor Ed Conway our city
editor Mark Kleinman and our business
presenter Ian King all giving their
expert analysis as well as their
insights into the crisis and you can
scan the QR code that you can see on
screen right now to put your questions
about the crisis that Ed Mark and Ian
which they will answer at 1 30 as part
of that program
still to come here on the program do you
stay with us we've got lots coming up
including with claims that damage caused
to a major gas pipeline in the Baltic
Sea was an act of sabotage I'll be
speaking to the Danish foreign minister
yepa kufford
well we just heard from the government
at eight o'clock I'll be speaking to
Labor's Shadow Chief secretary to the
treasury Pat McFadden
and also get reaction to the market
turmoil with the former treasury
Minister Lord O'Neill
foreign
people are missing off the coast of
Florida and almost 2 million have been
left without power so let's find out the
very latest our U.S correspondent Martha
Kellner joins me now from Fort Myers in
Florida so Martha clearly it's very wet
where you are tell us just how bad it's
been
yeah it is wet there's still lashing
rain and rain and quite strong winds
here but nowhere near as bad as it's
been throughout the early hours of this
morning and certainly yesterday
hurricane Ian has now been downgraded to
a category one storm as expect as it
makes its way across Central and Eastern
Florida but it was Far Far stronger than
that when it made landfill not far from
here actually late yesterday afternoon
bringing with it winds well in excess of
100 miles per hour and it was the water
rather than the wind that people were
fearing here even before the event and
they were proven correct because it
brought with it storm surges of up to 18
feet in certain places and there are
areas of Fort Myers around five or six
miles from here that are still under
four or five feet of water and we know
that people are still awaiting rescue
the city of Fort Myers writing this
evening on social media that there is
responding to fires extensive flooding
and life-threatening conditions here is
our report on a devastating day for this
part of Southwest Florida
for Miles along Florida's southwest
coast roads have become Rivers this
state is used to hurricanes but it's as
if Ian was designed for Destruction
unusual in strength and size unleashing
its Fury here for several hours sending
entire homes and their contents tumbling
away
this used to be the main Highway in Fort
Myers Beach overwhelmed by a storm surge
a tsunami-like wall of water more than
10 feet in places Sanibel Island usually
home to over 6 000 people and
multi-million dollar Mansions swallowed
entirely
2.5 million people were told to evacuate
this area but many stayed behind
Jennifer and her parents were stranded
at their house in Fort Myers eventually
rescued by a local in a boat the water
was just coming in through the cracks
and then the water just kept coming and
within 10 minutes the water was
up to my chest within 10 minutes
from ankles to my chest the door that
goes out to the garage actually broke
off of the hinges in water just
gushing in
everywhere though
next thing you know it's above our heads
we were floating we're trying to stand
on furniture
anything that we could
um because it was way above our heads
what do you think would have happened if
that boat hadn't arrived at that point
um I don't think we would be here
they're taking Refuge alongside
evacuated residents at this hotel soon
they'll leave and return home hoping
theirs has escaped the worst of the
storm
but for many they'll be counting the
cost of this catastrophe long after the
water and wind has subsided
foreign
you can see from those pictures there
that there's been absolutely
catastrophic damage over a wide part of
this Coast of Florida there's also
inevitably been loss of life as well so
this is a secondary issue but it may
become a more important one there are
2.2 million people in this area of
Florida this evening still without power
they've been without power for several
hours now and it means that there are
families people who are looking for
relatives for friends and aren't able to
make contact with them it also means
that we're not yet getting a clear
picture of the extent of damage in
certain places it's only really when
Dawn breaks that we'll be able to get a
true idea of just what path of
Destruction hurricane Ian has wrought
but it's certainly been a devastating
event a catastrophic event for this part
of Florida probably the worst the worst
hurricane this particular area has
experienced in terms of damage and one
of the worst hurricanes that's made
landfall anywhere in the United States
Martha thanks very much indeed
now the U.S Navy has said it stands
ready to provide support to its allies
after what defense sources believe was a
deliberate attack on gas pipelines in
the Baltic Sea well the Nord stream
pipelines are a pair of offshore natural
gas pipelines which run deep under the
Baltic Sea from Russia to Germany
Nordstrom won the first has delivered
gas but the opening of North stream 2
was suspended in February
the first League was reported on Monday
on the nordstream 2 pipeline east of the
Danish island of bornholm then on
Tuesday two leaks were found on the
nearby nordstream one
well our International correspondent
Alex Rossi joins me now live from Moscow
Alex suspicions that this was an act of
sabotage so what's Russia saying about
it
well moscow's line is that this the
allegations that it is behind this which
are being made in some quarters by the
Europeans uh certainly the Polish have
gone on on record saying that they blame
uh the Kremlin for carrying her out this
we heard from Dimitri peskov who is
Vladimir Putin's spokesman and he said
that kind of allegation was predictably
stupid
um so the investigation uh continues but
of course the focus does Center on
mosque Moscow but there are big
questions Anna is why would anybody do
this because although you can see a
benefit for the Russians in the sense it
saw uh makes Energy prices uh go up it
creates political instability in
European countries that are supporting
uh Ukraine it also is a bit of an own
goal as well because they own the
pipeline they of course make money off
the gas the gas hasn't flowed even
through Nordstrom once since the Sun
mama so it is something of an own goal
and the other fact of all of this is
that Vladimir Putin can very easily just
turn the Taps on and off he doesn't
actually need to blow up the
infrastructure so the investigation
continues but there are warnings we may
never really know what has happened
until they can get close to those pipes
and at the moment there's too much
methane bellowing out they won't really
be able to do the tests that they need
on the lake bed to see if they've been
explosives used so at the moment it
really is something of a mystery
Alex Rossi thanks very much indeed
you can bring in now the leader of the
liberal Democrats and former energy
Minister sir Ed Davey a very good
morning to you David thanks very much
indeed for talking to to us I will come
on to what's going on in the markets in
just a moment but things we've just been
talking about these apparent attacks on
the North stream pipelines I wonder what
your view was as a former energy
Minister How concerned do you think we
should be about them
I think we should be very concerned
um listening to polish and danish
ministers they do suspect this was an
act of Russian terrorism and it's
another threat from the Kremlin to
Europe's energy supplies
um but we need to stand bold against
Russia supporting Ukraine and one thing
that is some good news is that the
pipeline from Norway to Poland that some
of us have long argued for the so-called
Baltic gas pipeline is going to now open
earlier than originally planned so the
threat to the energy supplies that to
Europe which to have a knock-on effect
to to our country into gas prices here
that threat is being mitigated is being
dealt with by some good action by our
European colleagues in Norway in Poland
and in Denmark
but if the north stream pipelines are
rendered unusable what could the impact
be on energy supplies to Europe and to
the UK
well at the moment there's almost no gas
going through Nordstrom so I personally
think it's likely that Nordstrom may
never reopen
and therefore the energy policy of
Europe of our country working with our
European colleagues needs to assume that
we need to get off Russian energy as
fast as possible that would be good for
our security it would ultimately calm
the markets and reduce prices for people
reduce people's bills and it would help
us tackle climate change
um and by the way that's one of my
worries about this Russian potential
Russian terrorism that we've seen
because this leaking methane will do
damage to our climate
um I think we need to stand shoulder to
shoulder with our European allies
and Labor's got an idea hasn't it to
help us wean ourselves off uh Russian
gas and and other supplies they are
seeking to establish a new state-owned
company a Great British energy what do
you make of their plan
well liberal Democrats in government are
quadrupled Britain's Renewable Power uh
we made Britain the world leader in
offshore wind we set up something called
the green Investment Bank which was a
state-owned bank which worked with
private investors to get huge amounts of
money tens of billions of pounds of
investment to achieve our renewable
goals regrettably the conservatives
privatize the green Investment Bank they
have cut investment in Renewables
um and so liberal Democrats support any
measures which is going to reverse that
I think actually Reinventing the liberal
Democrat uh green Investment Bank would
probably be the best and quickest
solution to massively increasing the
renewable investment that we need to see
in our country
so let's turn to the the market turmoil
how do you assess this crisis
well first of all it's a totally
unnecessary crisis this crisis has been
caused by the incompetence of this
conservative government
um I think there are millions of people
out there your viewers and many more who
are literally terrified about what is
happening
they're worrying about the impact on
their savings they're worried about the
impact on mortgage rates
and they're not seeing any leadership
from this government I watch your
interview with the chief secretary's
treasury Chris Phelps he was blaming
everyone else but the government
and No One Believes him No One Believes
this conservative government anymore
they've lost total credibility that's
why local Democrats have said we need to
recall Parliament the conservatives need
to cancel their conference so they can
get back to work get back to their
offices and sort this mess out they need
to come to Parliament next week reverse
the damage damaging announcements of
their budget last Friday and restore
confidence
and help people who are so fearful out
there give them some reassurance the
government's going to regain a grip on
economic policy
and should the chancellor resign
well personally I I think they should
all go uh uh liberal Democrats have long
argued for an early general election but
before that can happen this crisis has
to be fixed it is no good conservative
ministers going off to their conference
next week going to their cocktail party
is coughing champagne while the country
is in crisis
let's trust quasi quateng and the rest
of this amateur Bunch need to get back
to their offices stop their conference
and sort this mess out and come to
Parliament and be held accountable
that's what liberal Democrats want to
see on behalf of the British people we
need to turn this utter catastrophe the
self-inflicted wound round and that
means a concert is for once admitting
they have got it very badly wrong
so Ed David thanks very much indeed
foreign
takes emergency action to avert what it
calls material damage to UK Financial
stability I'll be speaking to a former
Economist at the bank about what's next
[Music]
let's get you up to date with what's
been happening in the markets well
speaking to the program this morning the
chief secretary to the treasury said he
would not apologize for the market
turmoil that's followed the government's
mini budget Chris philp defended the
government's plans saying they are a
strategy for growth
uh well no one's perfect
um but I think I'm not gonna sort of
apologize for having a plan to grow the
UK's economy which will increase
people's wages that will create new jobs
I'm certainly not going to apologize for
having an energy Intervention which is
protecting every single household in
this country from what could have been
devastating bills this winter
well our political correspondent Tamara
Cohn is here with me so too is carsten
Young Who I'll be talking to in just a
moment but um tomorrow to you first of
all so the government looks like it just
doesn't want to back down on this many
budget well we're now seeing treasury
ministers being wheeled out to defend
the budget there is no sense that they
think anything was done wrong there were
no mistakes they say it was well
received by businesses on the day and
that jars even with what the chancellor
quasi-huate told Tory MPS on a call the
day before yesterday many jittery Tory
MPS worried about their own mortgages as
well as those of their constituents he
said perhaps the markets were not
prepared for some of the measures that
hadn't been trailed in advance such as
the cut to the 45p rate but Chris philp
there and other treasury ministers are
saying look there's no sense of Crisis
this is all due to global forces even
though of course the view from other
countries is this is constrained to the
UK and the IMF have not warned at any
other countries in this way he said that
the government disagrees with the
internet National monetary funds
analysis that this budget deepens
inequality and that borrowing is out of
control he says that the government will
set out its plans at the end of November
we're also due to hear from the Prime
Minister this morning for the first time
in about a week she's going to be doing
a round of regional interviews and if
this is anything to go by she is going
to be staunchly defending the measures
that she took but as to the growing
anxiety among many people about how
they're going to cope with the impact on
mortgages as well as the rising cost of
living in other areas there really
wasn't very much reassurance from the
treasury secretary and that will worry
MPS a great deal and speaking to some
yesterday really they were saying we
believe that the conservative party may
have just lost its reputation for
economic competence in one Fell Swoop
yeah and a few of them speaking publicly
but not many at this stage so let's
bring in Carson Jung you are a senior
Economist at the ippr's center for
economic justice but you've also worked
at the bank of England and also the IMF
as well so you're very well placed to
comment on what's going on at the moment
and we have had an extraordinary week
haven't we yesterday extreme turmoil on
the bond market we've seen the pound
falling to record lows against the
dollar earlier in the week as well as we
heard there as tomorrow was was summing
up what the the government is is saying
they say that we're just one of many
countries experiencing pressures like
this is that right or are we suffering
peculiarly because of the mini budget if
you listen to what people in markets are
saying and what they're putting out the
view is very clear that this has been
due to the mini budget uh you know the
pound fell four percent on the day of
the budget not the day before when the
bank of England made their announcement
so it was clearly a response to the huge
fiscal hole that the chancellor is
punching into public finances you know
unfunded tax cuts which are undermining
Public Services pulling the rug from
underneath the economy so even the
international monetary fund has come out
and has said this doesn't stack up it's
not sustainable and moreover it
exacerbates inequality at the time of a
cost of living crisis if the government
had
got the obr the office for Budget
responsibility to issue its report
alongside the budget they do an
assessment at times of budgets and
financial statements usually don't they
where they assess what the impact would
be on the economy and how it would be
paid for would that have made all the
difference so that was a huge problem
that the government said we don't want a
transparent assessment of this huge
physical Intervention which what is what
we should have expected but even if
they've done so what the obr would
likely have said is you're punching a 45
billion fiscal hole in the public
finances at the time when
schools hospitals the police will need
more cash injections just to stand still
in a time of inflation and the obr would
have said you know there might be
further cost of living packages needed
the last one cost 15 billion just to
help low and middle earners to stay
afloat and these numbers just don't add
up it's a huge fiscal hole and the obr
would have set certainly something along
those lines and without the obr the
markets have made that call well that
statement will now come at the end of
November we will we will get their word
on this won't weren't they what should
happen now would it help if they brought
forward that assessment would that
reassure the markets it might assure
markets a little bit but it won't change
the fundamentals you know these are Big
Numbers we can't uh you know brush over
this and say oh growth is a little bit
higher it'll all be fine so the OBS
assessment one way or another will be
quite daunting and the only way I see to
car markets is to reverse course
um plug these holes don't cut taxes
which mostly benefit the better off in a
time where we should stand together and
we should be increasing taxes in this
cost of living crisis as is discussed
elsewhere if you look at the European
Central bank chief Economist for example
here said this is the time to increase
taxes on those with the broadest
shoulders to support those on low and
middle incomes that is sensible
economics and I think this is the only
way to reassure markets we know that
government departments are going to be
told today by the treasury to find
efficiencies to find Cuts how severe
will they have to be
very severe so if you know on average
over the next five years this is 30
billion whole in public finances you
will have to make big adjustments and
let's let's not forget
public sector wages have been far below
inflation so these efficiencies could
very well mean that nurses doctors don't
have their pay even remotely keep up
with inflation on the contrary it may
further they may further decline so a I
don't think we can get that much out of
efficiencies and B we really need to
support Public Services right now in
order to you know support people that
are working for the public sector and of
course A lot of people are worried about
Rising bills they're worried about
mortgages a lot of mortgage offers have
been withdrawn now and products
generally in that market as well
and people are worried about their
pensions as well the government says
hold fire this is a growth plan you'll
all benefit in the future and we're
protecting you against the worst rises
in costs with our energy plan can people
relax today
they cannot I mean for many uh that that
future may never arrive if it means
they're losing their home if it means uh
they they lose their job or they you
know can't eat their homes this winter
so you know we're seeing uh you know
with this fiscal package by the
chancellor interest rates are now
expected by markets to go up to five six
percent this for many people on flexible
mortgages this could almost double their
mortgage payments monthly these are huge
huge shocks to people which we haven't
seen in the last 50 years to incomes and
a lofty claims about a brighter growth
in in five to ten years to come you know
won't won't help many people right now
who are really struggling
and yet the pound appears to have found
a fairly stable level the intervention
by the bank of England and the bond
market yesterday seems to have
stabilized that market for now it is the
worst this crisis over
so the intervention by the bank of
England showed uh in what Jeopardy uh
they've been put in by the government
because they were remember they were in
inflation taming mode where they were
trying to take steam out of the economy
um and you know increase rates and what
the turmoil yesterday has forced them to
do is to pump more money into markets to
to come things down so they are now
stuck between a rock and a hard place
having to pump money in but really they
want to be in an inflation fighting mode
and I think financial markets are by no
means uh relaxed about this the pound
could well fall further as a result of
inflation that is now expected to go
even higher
so we're expecting to hear next formally
from the government at the end of
November do you think they'll have to
say something before then in terms of
economic plans I I think so financial
markets are really concerned I'm most
importantly people in the UK are really
concerned with their mortgages
skyrocketing
um mortgage lenders not even giving them
out anymore because they don't know
where markets will be tomorrow and
inequality skyrocketing because uh you
know there's being tax cuts for the
wealthy and those and lowers incomes
their incomes are not keeping up with
inflation so a real real pressures both
by financial markets and uh by by
Ordinary People which we haven't seen at
least since the financial crisis SO
waiting till November seems an
incredibly long time and I think we need
to reverse calls now take back these tax
cuts to make sure there is a stable
footing for this state to act and to to
address some of these problems coming
down the line we even need to increase
taxes for example on energy producers
who are still making win for profits as
well as others who have broad shoulders
well Carson Jung very interesting to get
your take on all of this and tomorrow as
ever thanks very much indeed to you too
of course
nothing let's return to the damage to
the nordstream pipeline and officials in
Denmark have been clear in their
assessment that the leaks were not
caused by accident well the Prime
Minister yesterday said that they were
the result of deliberate actions but
that it's not yet clear who is behind it
well I'm joined now by the Danish
foreign minister yepper kafford so
welcome to you tell us exactly what you
think happened to the Nordstrom
Pipelines
well what we can see from all available
information is that there's been huge
explosions at the pipelines uh both
north room one and two that led to the
to the Titanic leaks that we have seen
and now um so that is what we know so it
was intentional not an accident or
um or something like that and we are now
working very hard with all of the
countries in Europe around the Baltic
Sea in particular to establish the facts
so we can so we can investigate what
what happened here this is a I want to
emphasize this is uh International
matter concerning all countries around
the Baltic Sea and and in Europe it
happened in international waters in our
exclusive economic zone and Swedish
inclusive economic zone but but it's
something that is concerning all of us
well yes and I noticed that that some
are
sticking their neck out to a certain
extent I noticed that a German
opposition politician is saying that
it's likely that Russia was behind the
attack do you agree
I don't want to go into any speculations
uh on who we could attribute the attack
to but but I want to assure everybody
that we will investigate and also with
all of our partners in EU and NATO to
ensure that we will uh we will
establish the facts as we go on it's
very important for us that that is done
and we're looking at all the data now so
so we will get back to the public when
we have more information to to release
and how can the EU and NATO respond in
your view
well I think this is unprecedented we
haven't seen that kind of attack or
sabotage on a critical European energy
infrastructure
um and therefore we we do not take this
uh very easy it's something which we
were working closely with our allies in
EU and NATO we came out with with also a
decoration yesterday morning from eu27
or EU countries and and we're working
with NATO partners and I've spoken to
the US and of course a lot of other
allies in Europe on this issue and will
continue to do until we we find out what
happened and and who did it and and why
did this take place in in in in the
Baltic Sea
and Norway's prime minister said its
military are going to be more visible at
oil and gas installations is that a move
that you support is that something that
you'd be doing
it's clear we all need to be very aware
of our critical infrastructure when it
comes to Unity and other infrastructure
so we all take I think the right
precautionary steps because it is
unprecedented as I've said we haven't
seen that type of attack on on on
infrastructure this is pipelines running
international waters in the Baltic Sea
and North stream one and two and it's
very close to our territories in Sweden
and and Denmark so so it's something we
we take very seriously and therefore we
we all have to look out for for for our
critical infrastructure
and of course Europe's been determined
to wean itself off Russian gas something
that's been talked about here as well of
course what are the implications do you
think of this damage to the pipelines on
supplies
well it's been clear for us for a long
time in Denmark and also now for the
rest of Europe that we need to get out
of any dependence on Russian energy
whether it's gas coal or oil and we're
working very hard to obtain that
objective in Europe and Denmark is doing
its part we will focus a lot in
investing massively in renewable energy
not least to Offshore wind and other
type of Renewables and also Energy
Efficiency so so that is a course we
will not change and I think what
happened in the Baltic Sea with the
Nordstrom one and two just underlying
the importance of getting out of of
dependence of Russia
Danish foreign minister thanks very much
indeed we appreciate your time this
morning thank you
you're welcome
it's other headlines and a court in
military ruled Myanmar has convicted Ang
tsuchi in another criminal case
receiving a three-year sentence under
the secrets act Australian Economist
Sean turnel was sentenced with the
former Myanmar leader to three years for
violating an official's Secrets law
tsuki was detained when her elected
government was ousted by the Army last
year
the labor MP has accused the labor party
of targeting her saying she experienced
factionalism and racism speaking at the
world transformed festival at the labor
conference absana begum said she
received no support from the party when
she was suspect subjected to a vote on
her deselection while signed off sick
from work
two aircraft have been involved in a
minor collision at Heathrow Airport
emergency services at the scene said no
injuries have been reported but were
attending to ensure that all passengers
and crew are safe and well
now he may be better known as Alan
Partridge on screen but Steve Coogan's
views on Modern Britain are far from
obvious the actor has told us that the
government's recent tax cuts showed
breathtaking audacity his new film is
about a far more ancient ruler as our
entertainment reporter clay Gregory
reports
I know I can find him who Richard who
sorry uh the third
the king his latest film is about an
ordinary woman fighting against an
establishment that isn't interested in
helping her and Steve Coogan whose
previously campaigned for labor and the
lib Dems has told Sky News its themes
seem pertinent given the new
government's economic plans certainly
it's breathtaking
that at a time when there are so many
vulnerable people out there who are
going to be struggling to see the
government give tax breaks to the one
percent is uh breathtaking in its
audacity
the Lost King tells the story of amateur
historian Philippa Langley who led the
search for the remains of King Richard
III to a car park in Leicester a find
often credited to the city's University
my guess is that Anthony was adopted and
sent to America
project says railed against misogyny he
last teamed up with the director and his
co-writer from the Lost King on
Philomena about another woman fighting
for the truth why not as a privileged
white middle-aged man uh there is a
question mark of whether I should be
telling that story or I should be
involved in telling that story but when
you are in that position it makes you
work doubly hard at trying to make sure
you do justice to someone else's story
and the subject of the Lost King says
she's just glad her tail is being told I
think it's an important story to show
that you know what some an ordinary
person can do because I'm not a doctor
I'm not a professor
and and I hope it just inspires you know
like the Young
to to do something similar sprinkled
with humor this film is ultimately
entertainment but in crediting a
middle-aged woman with the discovery of
a king it may just have an impact on the
history books as well Claire Gregory Sky
News
now the rapper Coolio has died at the
age of 59.
as I walk through the valley of the
shadow of death I take a look at my life
and realize
or best known for his 1990s hit
Gangster's Paradise the US artist whose
real name is artist Leon Ivy Jr was
visiting a friend in Los Angeles when
according to his manager he suffered a
heart attack and tributes had been
coming in from fellow musicians all
morning for example the rapper Ice Cube
tweeted this is sad news eyewitness
first hand this man's grind to the top
of the industry rest in peace
another rapper Snoop Dogg simply said
Gangster's Paradise R.I.P